a public opinion survey investigated
whether a majority more than 50 percent
of adults supported a tax increase to
help fund the local school system a
random sample of 200 adults showed that
113 of those sampled supported the tax
increase
researchers used these results to test
the null hypothesis is that the
proportion is 0.5 the alternative
hypothesis is that it's greater than 0.5
where p is the true proportion of adults
that support the tax increase they
calculated a test statistic statistic of
z is approximately equal to 1.84 and a
corresponding p-value of approximately
0.033
assuming the conditions for inference
were met which of these is an
appropriate conclusion and we have our
four conclusions here at any point i
encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can answer it for yourself
but now we will do it together and just
make sure we understand what's going on
before you we even cut to the chase and
get to the answer
so what we do is we have this population
and we are going to sample it so n is
equal to 200 from that sample we can't
calculate a sample proportion of adults
that support the tax increase we see 113
out of 200 supported which is going to
be equal to
let's see that is the same thing as
56.5 percent
so 56.5 percent
and so the key is is to figure out the
p-value what is the probability of
getting a result this much above the
assumed proportion or greater at least
this much above the assumed proportion
if we assume that the null hypothesis is
true and if that probability if that
p-value is below a preset threshold if
it's below our significance level they
haven't told it to us yet it looks like
they're going to give some in the
choices well then we would reject the
null hypothesis which would suggest the
alternative
if the p-value is not lower than this
then we will fail to reject the null
hypothesis
now to calculate that p-value to
calculate that probability what we what
we figure out is well how many in our
sampling distribution how many standard
deviations above the mean of the
sampling distribution and the mean of
the sampling distribution would be our
assumed population proportion how many
standard deviations above that mean is
this right over here and that is what
this test statistic is
and then we can use this to look at a z
table and say all right well in a normal
distribution what percentage or what is
the area under the normal curve that is
further than 1.84 standard deviations or
at least 1.84 or more standard
deviations above the mean and they did
that for us as well
so really what we just need to do is
compare this p-value right over here to
the significance level if the p-value
is less than our significance level then
we reject
reject our null hypothesis and that
would suggest the alternative
if this is not true then we would fail
to reject the null hypothesis so let's
look at these choices and if you didn't
answer it the first time i encourage you
to pause the video again
so at the alpha is equal to 0.01
significance level they should conclude
that more than 50 percent of adults
support the tax increase
so if the alpha is 100 the p-value right
over here is over 300 it's roughly 3.3
percent so this is a situation where our
p-value
our p-value is greater than or equal to
alpha in fact it's definitely greater
than alpha here and so here we would
fail
to
reject
we would fail to reject our null
hypothesis and so we wouldn't conclude
that more than 50 of adults support the
tax increase because remember our null
hypothesis is that 50 do and we're
failing to reject this so that's not
going to be true
at that same significance level they
should conclude that less than 50
percent of adults support the tax
increase
no we can't say that either we just
failed to reject this null hypothesis
that the true proportion is 50
at the alpha is equal to so at the alpha
equals to 500 significance level they
should conclude that more than 50
percent of adults support the tax
increase
well yeah in this situation we have our
p-value
which is
0.033 it is indeed less than our
significance level in which case we
reject
reject the null hypothesis and if we
reject the null hypothesis that would
suggest the alternative that the true
proportion is greater than 50 percent
and so i would pick this choice right
over here and then choice d at that same
significance level they should conclude
that less than 50 percent of adults
support the tax increase no not not the
situation at all if we're rejecting our
null hypothesis right over here then we
should it should suggest this
alternative